- [Narrator] When I was 12 years old,
I went on vacation to
Alaska with my family.
While walking down one of
the cold stone covered beaches,
I spotted a large pile of rocks
that seemed to have slid
off the side of one of the hills
that connected to the shore.
These rocks caught my eye
due to their peculiar outer rust color
that contrasted with the rest
of the rocks on the beach.
As I began curiously looking through them,
I accidentally knocked a few over.
Splitting some in the process.
But to my surprise,
one of the rocks that split in half
had a secret hidden within it.
Inside with the imprint
of a tiny pine cone
and nearby was rock covered
in the imprints of leaves.
I was so excited because that day
I'd found real plant fossils,
but what exactly are fossils
and what can they tell us?
Fossils are preserved
evidence of organisms
that lived in the distant past.
They can be made up of
many different things
like bones, shells, plants,
or even markings like footprints
that tell us about an
organism's behaviors.
These preserved remains
are mostly made possible
by specific kind of rock
known as sedimentary rock.
Sedimentary rock is formed
from compressed layers of sediment,
which is a mixture of rocks, minerals,
and organic matter.
Sediment is the result of erosion,
which is when bits of rock or soil
break down and get
deposited somewhere else.
Sediment is deposited in layers,
one on top of the other.
over millions of years,
these layers become compressed,
eventually solidifying
and forming sedimentary rock.
But how do the fossils
even get inside of these rocks?
Well, let's look back
at the fossil I found.
If I had to guess,
a long time ago,
some leaves and a pine cone
must have fallen to the ground
and gotten covered in sediment.
As more sediment layered on top of them,
the plants pressed an imprint
of their shape and patterns
into the sediment.
Over time, the sediment
compressed into rock
and the original plant decayed,
but its imprint stayed inside the rock.
Then finally, my fossil sat
until I literally stumbled upon it.
So now that we know what fossils are,
what can they tell us?
As I mentioned before,
fossils are like little time machines
that can show us what types of organisms
where alive millions
or even billions of years ago.
And they can show us how life
on Earth has changed over time.
But in order to unlock these secrets,
scientists have to estimate
the ages of the fossils they find.
This can be done in two main ways.
Either by looking at which layers
of the sedimentary rock
the fossils are found in
or by using a process known
as radiometric dating.
Let's talk about layer analysis first.
As you know, sedimentary rocks
are formed in layers
with each new layer
forming on top of an old layer.
This means that the layers
that are closer to the surface
tend to be newer than the layers
that are deeper in the ground.
This means that a fossil
found in a deeper layer
of undisturbed sedimentary rock
will be older than the ones
found closer to the top.
By looking through these layers,
we're able to not only
tell how old a particular fossil may be,
but we can also look into
the patterns of fossils
over multiple layers
to see how life on Earth
has changed over time.
The second way scientists
estimate a fossil's age
is through a process known
as radiometric dating.
Radiometric dating tells us
how old a fossil is
by studying its chemical properties.
Specifically, radiometric dating
looks at the decay,
or the loss of particles,
from certain radioactive
atoms in the fossils.
Scientists know how
fast this decay happens.
So by measuring the amount of decay
that has occurred,
scientists can estimate
the age of the fossil.
Once scientists know
how old the fossil is,
it can then be added to
Earth's Fossil Record.
Earth's Fossil Record
consists of all the fossils found on Earth
along with their relative ages.
And it provides us
with the big picture view
of the history of life on Earth.
And with that,
you now know how fossils
are formed and dated.
Let's go back through
the layers of this lesson
and go over what we've learned today.
Fossils are preserved evidence
of organisms that lived long ago.
This evidence of life
is most commonly found
in layers of sedimentary rock.
Now, depending on how deep they are
in the layers of sedimentary rock
or their results from radiometric dating,
fossils can be given an estimated age
and be placed on Earth's fossil record.
Now, when it comes to the fossil I found,
it wasn't a major discovery
like the discoveries of the Ichthyosaur,
Plesiosaur fossils found
by paleontologist Mary Anning,
but it made me realize
that discovering fossils
is not carried out
strictly by professional scientists.
You and I can both find fossils too.
All we need is a keen eye, some patience,
and maybe a little bit of luck.